the detail the colors the beauty the
Integrity absolute Integrity with Ruth
Carter
[Music]
itself is such a concept we really
wanted to come back to it this film
gives you more more military landscape
cultures technology that's upgraded and
much more food
Carter really just took the initiative
and pushed the film further than I could
ever imagine I just kind of keep my eyes
and ears open to the brilliant start
bringing it to life
we want to present the wakanda that
people know and the door milage we're a
big part of that wakandan culture we
also wanted to upgrade their armor and
give them the ability to swim in that
costume so we had to create the new door
melange is giving us PhD graduate beyond
beyond level the embroidery the jewelry
The Capes the headdress she just took it
up a notch Heaven seems to be working
diligently rules will exhaust every
possibility in terms of her research to
build this world of wakanda and not just
wakanda this time Nile the telecon
my people call me
but my enemies call me no more we are
all trying to make this as accurate as
possible but we're creating a subculture
the tolocanillo they live under water
for thousands of years so we went from
historical reference to imagination it's
beautiful to see Ruth really go the
extra mile and get that resource get
that knowledge and Infuse it into this
film
working with Ruth is really fascinating
because she's the calmest Creator I know
and she's so humorous and light as she's
creating these really intense costumes
that are going to inform cosplay for
attacking to come or more you know to
come back to wakanda to be able to
present African culture in a futuristic
way that was not colonized and certainly
a highlight in my career
[Music]
foreign